hey this is my Carnac if you are
watching practical examples in react
today we're going to implement public
and protected routes using react router
let's dive into some code we're running
a basic react application here via code
sandbox do all the react router
components used in a web application
should be imported from react router
dump so let's go ahead and add that
dependency to react router Dom let's
create a component called landing page
we're going to return a react component
here first we import react from react
we're going to export landing page as a
functional component
let's return some markup here and I'm
going to return landing page here when I
save it's going to rearrange the the
markup all right going back to index
we're going to import our landing page
oops
from the landing page and let's let's
load the landing page right here and
notice that landing page prints right
there all right
next we're going to import browser
router from react router dump
browser router basically gives access to
the history API and keeps the UI in sync
with the URL now we need to wrap our app
component with browser router let's go
ahead and do that alright everything
still works as expected
let's import route and switch from react
router Dom we're going to convert
landing page to a grout so let's remove
landing page here we're going to create
a route component and pass in landing
page as a component reference to route
so notice that landing page loads here
anytime a route does not specify a path
it will load a component regardless of
what's in the URL so let's make this
load only when the path equals root or
slash let's try going to slash app
notice what happens landing page is
still loading that's because it does a
prefix match and so essentially it
matches on slash here and still loads
landing page what we need to do is
specify the exact property so that it
only loads when the route is the route
in this case we're going to create a
component called appellee out which
we'll load when we specify the app route
first let's take care of returning a
react component here so we are going to
return react from sorry import react
from react and then we're going to
return or export a constant called
app layout which is going to equal to a
function and we're going to return some
markup here let's call this back layout
and on the same it's gonna reorder
everything now let's go back to index
and we're going to import app layout
from the app layout file and let's
create another route here so if I copy
and paste this notice that you will get
two instances of landing page I'm going
to replace this with happily out and we
only want appellee out to load when the
path matches slash app so it disappears
there now if I were to put in app it's
going to load happily up if I were to
remove app here and
go back to the root it's gonna show
landing page now what if we wanted to
protect components under the app route
and only make them available to users
who were authenticated before we can do
this let's create a file called auth is
to track the login status this class
will export an instance of the class so
that we mimic the singleton pattern and
internally we're going to create a
constructor with the property called the
startup gente gated and set that
defaults will create a login method
which will set this start authenticated
to true and let's also take in a
callback simulating some asynchronous
operation here going back to the server
and coming back and when it's done it'll
call back to the color likewise let's do
a logout call they call back here this
is going to set authenticated to false
and we're gonna call the callback and
finally we're going to create an is
authenticated method which is going to
return the status of authenticated
indicating it for logged in or not in
the real world scenario you would end up
managing your authentication via an
interface like this that provides some
abstraction so essentially you could be
loading stuff from your local storage or
the server side or look at your cookie
etc let's go to our landing page and
create a button for logging in
so let's create a button here I'm gonna
move this to an h1 tag and on click
I would like to handle the callback
right here
let's reference off from now this is all
lowercase because we're expecting an
instance of the auth object we're going
to call and we're going to call auth dot
log in with a callback method that gets
triggered when logging is successful we
want to redirect the user to the app so
we're going to use a property called
history and push the app route to it
this will tell the react router to
change the URL to slash app and then
redirect the the user to the app route
so let's go ahead and click login and we
have an error here that's because this
is a functional component and props
should be a parameter alright so let's
try logging in again and notice that we
go to app layout and the pad changes to
app although we're redirecting to app
we're not checking if the user is
actually logged in so going back to
index GS we're going to create a new
component called protected route and
this component is going to import from
react it's going to input react from
react and then we're simply going to
export a constant called protected route
which is again a functional component
and we are going to return a route we
need to make sure to import route before
we can use this from react route or DOM
and we're going to pass in component as
a prop here which we will be structure
and call it component with a capital C
and rest of the properties that are
passed in will be D structured into rest
we're going to pass in all the rest of
the props into route followed by a
render prop which is basically a
property call render and the the value
for it is a functional component and we
have to return our component this
function gets a few props passed of it
in case we wanted to pass some
properties from our route definition
into component so we're going to pass
those along and I've made that mistake
here I need to enclose this in brackets
since we're D structuring or
restructuring this now when I save it's
gonna reorder everything now let's go
back to index es so far everything loads
let's import our protected route from
protected route and we're going to copy
that and simply replace this route here
for app so let's save it so it's going
to restructure everything so far
everything seems to work okay now all
protected route is doing is it's
returning a route with the component
that's passed in in our case it's the
Apple a out as a render prop we also
need to check if the user is actually
logged in so let's import off from auth
and inside of our function here we're
going to check if user is authentic
and if that's the case we're going to
return a component else we're going to
redirect the user so we're gonna return
a redirect component so we need to
import redirect from react router Dom
we're going to render a redirect
component I'm sorry a return a redirect
component which will tell it to go to a
specific path which is passing as an
object with a property called path name
now this is available in the react
router documentation we're also gonna
pass a state prop to it or a value for
its state which tells it that we're
coming in from whatever location we were
trying to go to which will be passed in
here to rest and then through props and
finally down here let's implement a
logout button in the appellee out I'm
going to start out by turning this into
an each one followed by adding a button
component that's gonna be called logout
and on click we want to call auth dot
log out so let's import off from the
auth file and we're gonna call off dot
log out which also takes a call back and
so when logout is successful we're going
to call this dot props
history DUP push and tell it to go back
to the root now the reason history is
available on props here is because we
loaded it be a route so the route object
or component passes in a prop called
history down to
landing page or to a plea out remember
predicted route is still route
internally and that's why we have access
to this dot props dot history if we had
a separate component we had created here
then it would not have access to history
and in that case we would need to import
with router from oops from react router
dump and then use that as a higher-order
component let's go ahead and click log
out and we have an error here and I mean
the same mistake here that's not because
I normally work with classes and for the
purpose of this demo I had decided to
use functional components so I click
login and goes to AB layout and click
logout goes back to landing page now the
reason we see protectively a crowd are
printed is because in our index TS i am
printing that here so we can remove that
what happens if we were to go to some
random URL here i click enter
nothing loads so in that case you would
want to define a route which would
handle every other path that's not
defined and we won't basically render a
404 page in this so something like 404
not found right but when I load this oh
I forgot to close this here so when I
when I go to a random route that's what
happens but notice what I have what
happens when I go back to the route
right I still see 404 not found and the
reason is because we imported this
component called switch but we haven't
used it yet it essentially acts like a
switch statement so we just want to
stick it up here
in between sorry around the routes and
it sort of acts like a switch statement
where it will stop after the first route
that matches
notice that the forefront found is gone
it's still there if I type in some junk
here we're gonna get 404 not found and
now going back here login still takes us
to a play out logout will take us the
landing page hope you enjoyed this video
if you have any questions or comments
write them below and subscribe to my
channel to be notified of future videos
thank you
[Music]